hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play SCP
containment breach
alright you guys told me that I was
right next to gate a which so I had to
get back in here as soon as possible
I am Thor you still be computer stupid
sentient machine okay you guys told me
that I was gosh dang it stop it
you said I was right exit 8a it's
writing ah gonna kill someone
alright this was gay day this is gay day
how do I open gate a but gay day is
closed how do I help oh hello ah ah
huh no no how do i I can't see [ __ ] it
seemed to be locked how do I get on how
do I get there
ah who's that who did that who did that
who did that oh it's open
okay so hang on I don't like those
sounds those sounds are bad okay whoa
what done holy balls
good eye ah new ending oh yes oh that
doesn't sound good
whatever that is don't sound good
so let's get out of here oh hey hi I see
you ah that a gun oh hey whoa
what was that what is going on
okay they're not pointed at me okay so
this is all I get it
oh they are shooting wait who's shooting
at me birthday kit I don't want to die
don't want to die here need to see this
haha okay so he melted into the floor oh
no I'm being shot damn it I don't
maybe I wasn't supposed to cross the
bridge maybe I was not okay
dammit dammit dammit I [ __ ] up oh now
I can see clearly why can I see clearly
now
why did everything decide to brighten up
for me okay damn it I was so close that
means I could just put this on perp walk
whoosh alright sorry about that I should
have saved her rah in here nailed it
get me down get me down loading screen
up see aha ah okay so where is one of
six popping up here oh there he is okay
ah okay so I'm gonna stay behind him
that way I don't have to run away go one
Oh sex
well stop dancing like a ballerina and
get out there go man go
radical Larry go man go
you're a badass let it across the bridge
Brad what you gonna do what's gonna do
sorry I totally forked up them
would be dying and all that
Wow okay so what's gonna happen after he
escapes wait what's this down here wait
what's this what's this then I'm not
actually gonna save here I can't save in
this location okay wait so can I escape
this way they're not looking they're
totally not looking it I can totes get
out maybe what's here what do we got
here wall
what is this what is this huh what'd you
say ha you know too much trouble game
you're coming with us
what Oh
the target
are you saying that the tunnel collapse
done
to collapse
haha okay I don't know if that was all
about there must have been something
else there but I don't know act anyway
that that is the new ending gang yeah I
have officially found all of the new
content in SCP containment breach since
the last update I will resume SCP
containment breach once there is a new
update of significant content and then
we will see the terror that is this game
again 106 was not one oh six oh nine -
oh nine six oh nine six I think it was
that that was a really really really
really freaky one I hope they do more
with him in the next in the next update
because him being added I mean just the
way he is he's just kind of there you
can easily avoid him if you
intentionally stare them in the face
that something happens but I bet I've
been in the next update they got
something in store for him because he's
a great addition and hopefully more with
682 because they've been hinting at 682
happening for quite a while now so thank
you all so much for watching hope you
enjoyed this and SCP containment breach
so far and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye
ah